all right so  in case you missed it this week we  debuted cbs morning's deals we share  some items that might help make your  life a little easier all at exclusive  low prices we highlighted the jump start  and this is a do it all 10 in one tool  that includes jumper cables flashlight  phone charger and so much more to get a  deal on that jumpstart and many other  items that may help you save money and  time scan the qr code on your screen you  can also visit  cbsdeals.com and tune in on tuesday we  will show you some items that could help  you save time on your household chores  and we all need to save a little time on  those chores that's for sure i just  don't do them often you know i just let  it be  okay tony all right lord be dirty i just  love how nate sells it man  i really sell it